[Musique]
nous sommes avec bar à tapas en khâgne à
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous baratte
pangkhan ya j'espère que vous nous
entendez bien un bilan dont qui pourrait
en plus être sous-estimée car on compte
1 je le rappelle depuis peu les décès
dans les maisons de retraite comment
vous expliquer ce chiffre s il était
prévisible selon vous pour connaître les
malheureusement beaucoup de personnes
sont mortes c'est très triste et je
pense que d'ici la fin de la journée et
nous dépasserons l'italie s'est beaucoup
de personnes nous comptons le mort à
l'hôpital et les morts en maison de
retraite
effectivement les plus tôt et très élevé
comment vous expliquer ce très mauvais
bilan est ce que vous lui attribuez vous
à la politique du gouvernement
effectivement johnson qui misaient au
départ sur l'immunité collective on en
avait beaucoup parlé à gauche je ne sais
pas mais je pense que la réponse est
multiple un les aspects de cette réponse
est que le confinement a été lent il à
la mise en place du traçage a été lente
et également la mise en place de tests
de plus nous aurions immédiatement du et
des les maisons de retraite afin de
protéger les personnes qui s'y rendent
pour s'assurer que les personnes ne sont
pas infectés car si elles sont
contaminés alors elles sont très
vulnérables et beaucoup d'entre elles
mourront
effectivement vous parlez des maisons de
retraite ça a été une véritable
catastrophe sanitaire dans le pays c'est
ce qui explique ce lourd bilan au
royaume-uni précisément où et quand je
le pense
nous avons observées dans tout le pays
une augmentation des décès dans les
maisons de retraite dans la communauté
de personnes âgées qui sont extrêmement
fragiles et vulnérables
donc malheureusement lorsqu une
affection est introduite dans une de ces
communautés alors les personnes sont
rapidement comme contaminé et beaucoup
d'entre elles meurent alors mauvaise
gestion effectivement peut-être des
autorités également peut-être tout un
système de santé ars voix selon vous je
rappelle vous êtes expert en maladies
infectieuses à des cas et une autre
balle m'a les chemins wac et puis ce
n'est pas une mauvaise gestion mais il
faut être conscient que ce problème
l'année et il aurait fallu agir en
conséquence
nous avons malheureusement été très
lents dans nos actions de prévention
nous aurions dû repérer bien plutôt les
signaux d'alarmé et mettre en place des
plans d'actions immédiatement même si ce
sont des maisons de retraite privées
elles sont besoin de soutien et
interventions gouvernementales face à
une pandémie
comment vous expliquer justement cette
lenteur c'était un parti pris d des
autorités ou tout simplement une
sous-estimation de la gravité de cette
crise je pense effectivement qu'il ont
sous-estimé il pensait sans doute que la
contamination et la de dangerosité de la
maladie serait plus parce qu'elle ne
l'était il ne seront à terme mais je
pense effectivement qu'il s'agissait
d'une sous-estimation du scénario le
pire est malheureusement le coronavirus
s'est montré extrêmement infectieux et à
contaminer beaucoup de personnes selon
vous les mesures de confinement est ce
qu'elles ont été décidées à temps où
elle
aurait dû l'être plutôt sans aucun doute
ce nous aurions dû agir plus tôt
cela fait longtemps que nous le disons
et je souhaite être honnête sur ce point
nous pensons qu'un confinement plus
rapide aurait aidé il y avait aussi un
problème tout comme en france d'ailleurs
de la pénurie de masques de test est ce
que sur ce point le gouvernement est en
train de combler son retard
nous avons mis en place un confinement
qui nous a donné le temps nécessaire
pour nous réorganiser nous avons
construit des réserves de test et de
matériel de protection
donc nous testons mais je ne pense pas
que ce sont les systèmes de traçage qui
sont suffisants donc il y a encore
beaucoup de travail à accomplir afin que
le lecteur et le traçage soient
opérationnels en même temps car les deux
sont nécessaires
ma dernière question c'est peut-être
plus aux citoyens que je m'adresse que
l'expert des maladies infectieuses quel
est l'état d'esprit les britanniques
avec ce bilan effectivement qui est très
lourd à ce qu'ils ne sont inquiets et
est-ce qu'au contraire ils revendiquent
peut-être plus de liberté comme on peut
le voir dans certains pays anglo saxons
notamment aux états unis
c'est une question très difficile car
les personnes qui ont perdu des proches
sont en deuil ne s'exprime pas son pool
versées et d'autre part il ya des
personnes qui n'ont pas du tout été
touchés
et ces personnes ne se rendent pas
compte du danger
donc il y a les deux aspects il ya des
personnes très touchée très triste et
d'autres personnes qui veulent que
l'économie reparte c'est un numéro
d'équilibriste difficile mais il faut
être très clair sur ce point il faut
sauver des vies cela devrait être la
priorité
merci baraquements cagnard rappelle que
vous êtes expert en maladies
infectieuses à l'université
que ces terres au royaume uni